في اليوم السابع من فاجعه الزلزال المدمر
في سوريا وتركيا يخف الامل في العثور على
ناجينا كسور طبعا باستثناء قله محظوظه
خرجت من تحت الانقاذ رغم مضيء مئات
الساعات تحت الركام في اليوم السابع انشغل
عمال الانقاذ برفع جثث من قضى وسط توقعات
امميه باي يتجاوز عدد الضحايا الاربعين
الف وتاكيد امم ايضا بان خمسه ملايين شخص
يواجهون خطرا دائما مشاهدينا التغطيه
مستمره انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه
الخامسه
[موسيقى]
ونبدا مشاهدينا الخامسه بمن انقذ اليوم في
هاتاي انتشل شاب بعد
151 ساعه من تحت الانقاذ وفي انطقيا تمكنت
فرق الدفاع المدني التركيه من انقاذ شخص
بقي عالقا لمده اسبوع تقريبا وليس بعيدا
عن غازي عنتاب انتشلت فرقه لانقاذ سيده
تبلغ من العمر 64 عاما على قيد الحياه بعد
اكثر من
150 ساعه تحت الانقاض دعونا نتابع
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
على قيد الحياه كلمه يتجدد معها الامل من
تحت الركام
151 ساعه تحت الانقاض قضاها الشاب عبد
الله تحت ركامي منزله المدمر فيها طاي
التركيه متمسكا بالحياه
خرج الى النور بعد سبعه ايام منظومه
الركام مانحا بارقه امل بدات بالتضاؤل مع
اقتراب مرور اسبوع على الكارثه
ومنها طاي الحزينه لم تتوقف قصص النجاه
والصمود
مزين اوف كلي السيده ذات الاربعه وستين
عاما لم يهزمها الزلزال وقوته خرجت من بين
الركام بعد 150 ساعه عثرت عليها فرق
الانقاذ وتم نقلها الى المستشفى واستصدمه
وفرحه المنقذين امل ضئيل تجدد باحتماليه
العثور على المزيد من الناجين وبتجاهل
سباق الزمن
جهود فرق الانقاذ المتواصله تمكنت من
انتشار شخص عمره 50 عاما بعد اسبوع من
بقائه تحت الركام في انطاكيا اما الرضيع
ذو الاشهر السبعه فيها الطاي فقضى 140
ساعه تحت الركام قبل ان تنجح فرق اطفاء
تركيه من انقاذه وبين عمليه انقاذ واخرى
يقف العشرات من الاهالي الناجين بملامح
تعكس الما كبيرا يتجمهرون حول فرق الانقاذ
متشبسين بمعجزه العثور على احياء ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا كما تابعنا على العواجل قفزت
ارقام واعداد القتلى في سوريا وايضا في
تركيا الى 35 الف قتيل كنا قبل حوالي
الربع ساعه من الان نتحدث عن 30 قتيل ولكن
يبدو ان تركيا اضافت 2600 قتيل اضافه
للارقام السابقه وبالتالي اصبح المجموع
الان كما ذكرنا 35 الف طبعا
واضافت تركيا كما ذكرنا 4600
حاله وفاه جديده هناك طبعا العمليات لا
زالت مستمره في المحاوله للبحث عن ناجين
ولكن ايضا في مدينه جبله هناك محاوله
العثور على ضحايا الزلزال شوهدت فرق
الانقاذ هي تحفر بين الانقاض وتحمل
الضحايا على نقلات المنقذون اكدوا
استئنافهم العمل في وقت مبكر من صباح هذا
اليوم واكدوا انتشالهم لجثث جديده
بسبب ظروف التيار اليوم
وصف عدد من السوريين الناجين من الزلزال
الذي ضرب بلده جنديرس بسوريا اللحظات
المروعه التي عاشوها مشبهين نجاتهم من
الموت بالمعجزه في ظل الضيق الوقت حينها
وقد وقعت الحيط على اخواتي بس انا الحمد
لله ما صابني شيء انا واختي وطلعنا من
البنايه
بعجوبه ما بعرف كيف نايمين حسينا على
الرجال انا
متغطي بحرمين
وتحت
الارض شوي
طفيت الكهرباء صارت رجع
الحيطان تهر على الاولاد البنايات عم تهبط
على الارض فاذا ارتبكنا ما عاد نعرف كيف
بدنا نساوي انا بس حاول بدي اسحب اولادي
حتى اجري ما عاد تشيلوني انا قاعد
حسيت ان الارض اتحرك من تحتي يعني في شيء
عم يتحرك من تحت يتجلس شوي زياده
صارت الحجار وتقع من حواليه والعماره صارت
تتحرك قمت انا فتحت الباب ونزلت على الدرج
وطلعت من جنب الدرج يعني خلال ثواني وقعت
البنيه اربع طوابق وقعت على الارض
جلود فيه منبج مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش
اهلا بك جمعه هل لا زال المشهد على حاله
ام هناك حركه الان انقل لنا المشهد
يعني ميسون ابدا من جنديرس حتى الان يعني
فرق الانقاذ تواصل البحث في المباني
المدمره لكنها لا تعثر سوى على
جثث يعني يمكن ان نقول مع مرور يومين لم
يتعثر فرق الانقاذ والبحث على ايه احياء
في الجموم الجغرافيا السوريه
العدد ارتفع رسميا يعني من قبل المعارضه
الى 2200 22 ومن قبل 1500 اضافه ميسون
يعني حتى الان حتى هذه اللحظات كنت اتابع
مع المعابر الاساسيه باب الهوى والراعي
وباب السلامه ارتفع عدد جثه السوريين التي
وصلت الى هذه المقابر الثلاثه الى 1300
جثه هؤلاء جميعهم قتلوا في الولايات العشر
في زلزال تركيا امام ميسون في المكان الذي
اقف فيفا انا اقف في معبر ام جلود الفاصل
بين مناطق الاداره الذاتيه والمعارضه شمال
غرب البلاد وتحديدا في مدينت المنبج من
طرف الاداره ومدينه جرابلس من طرف
المعارضه هنا
مع الصوره ل 30 شاحنه تحمل الوقود البنزين
والمازوت
قدمتها الاداره الذاتيه كقافله للمناطق
المنكوبه في شمال غرب البلاد لليوم الرابع
على التوالي لا تزال هذه الشاحنات
معالقه في المعبر كانت هناك اليوم محاوله
لادخالها حدث لقاء بين الاداره
والمعارضه
مندوب المعارضه عندما عاد الى منطقه
الراعي رجع الى هنا وقال بانهم لا
يستطيعون استلام هذه
القافله لماذا هناك اطراف نعم هناك اطراف
عده تحتاج الى اتخاذ قرار واحد وهذا امر
صعب سواء كان اداره المعبر او الحكومه
المؤقته او الفصائل او الدفاع
اين تتوزع يعني بدي اسمر الكعكه او انه
وين المشكله تكمن
يعني لا يعني الاساس فيها في في هذه
المشكله حقيقه كما يقول يعني المسؤولون
الاكراد هنا بان تركيا تضغط على الجهات
الفاعله داخل جسم المعارضه لمنع ادخال هذه
المساعدات ولا لانها لا تريد يعني التعامل
بين المعارضه والاداره الذاتيه وايضا لا
تريد اعطاء طابع رسمي في هذه العلاقه بين
الخصمين طبعا الخلافات السياسيه والعسكريه
يعني تتصدر المشهد وتعيق حركه دخول
المساعدات الانسانيه من هذه المعابر ومن
المناشدات اللي كانت حتى من قبل ان كان
الاداره او قبل المعارضه انه يجب اسقاط كل
ما له علاقه بالسياسه ويجب ان تكون
الانسانيه هي المحرك الرئيسي
في الحقيقه لا في هذه المعابر يعني
الواقعه يعني الفاصله بين مناطق الاداره
الذاتيه والمعارضه ولا حتى في المعابر غير
الرسميه الواقعه بين مناطق النظام
والمعارضه تبلونت فيها كل هذه التصريحات
للمسؤولين للمسؤولين والفرقاء السوريين لا
تزال المعابر بين مناطق النظام والمعارضه
مغلقا لم تشهد دخول اي مساعدات ايضا
المعابر بين مناطق الاداره والمعارضه لم
تدخل لم تشهد دخول اي مساعدات ايضا ميسون
هناك 100 شاحنه ايضا تحمل الوقود اضافه
الى شاحنات اخرى تحمل المواد الاغاثيه
والانسانيه عالقه ايضا في معبر التائهه
الذي لا يبعد طيب احنا جمعه بنعرف بنعرف
انه في دول كبرى لديها سيطره على الارض
ولديها كلمه
وبتمون اذا مصحه تعبير على فصائل دون
غيرها هل من تحرك لها
ابدا يعني هذا كان مطلب
للجهاد اجتماعيه ووجهاء عشائر وايضا حتى
من الاداره الادائيه بضروره
من الامم المتحده او حتى من الدول الفاعله
هنا سواء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
حتى روسيا لكن لما يحدث اي نوع من الوساطه
ميسون هناك احيانا اشتراطات خاصه في معبر
التائهه يعني الاداره تقول بان النظام
يطلب الحصول على
80% من اجمالي المساعدات العالقه في معبر
الدائحه وانا هنا اعود الى كلمه اقتسام
الكاكا لربما نظام يعني يحاول الحصول على
الحصه الاكبر منها من المساعدات العالقه
في التائهه عندما سالت المسؤولين الاكراد
قالوا نحن نرفض يعني تسييس هذه المساعدات
او اعطاء حصص لاي طرف كان نحن نحاول
ايصالها الى المنكوبين طبعا انا علمت ايضا
بان الاداره تريد ان توجه هذه المساعدات
الى مخيم الشهباء في حلب ويحتوي على عشرات
الالاف من النازحين من عفرين وايضا تحويله
تحويلها الى
حياي الاشرفيه والشيخ مقصود في مركز مدين
جمعه عندي سؤال فيما يتعلق نعم وعندي سؤال
فيما يتعلق بالجثث لانه يبدو هي الشغله
الوحيده التي تصل الى المنكوبين المزيد من
الجثث تاتينا الان من تركيا لمن فقدوا تحت
الزلزال ذكرت انه في 1300 جثه قد دخلت
الاراضي السوريه اين يتم دفنها وما هي
الاجراءات التي تتخذ
لمعرفه من هؤلاء
لاطلاع العائلات على وجود جثث لاحبائهم
ميسون يعني حتى الان معبر باب السلامه
استلم حوالي 1200 جثه اضافه الى معبر
الراعي ومعبر
باب عفوا معبر باب الهوى استلم اكثر من
ومعبر باب الراعي وايضا باب السلامه يتم
تسجيل هذه الجثث كاسماء في سجلات على
الاغلب هناك امم من الاهالي او حدا من
يعني المقربين من الدرجه الاولى يقومون
باستلام هذه الجثث ومن ثم يصار الى دفنها
فيما يمكن ان اعتبره مقابر جماعيا لانها
تثبت بشكل جماعي الجثث التي لا يتم التعرف
اليها او لم يحضر الاهل لاستلامها في
المعبر الرئيسيه تحول الى المشافي
لتضع في البرادات ثم انتظار الاهل للتعرف
عليها يعني سواء الذين الجثث التي دخلت من
المعابر او تلك التي عثر عليها تحت الارض
في سلقين او سرمدا او لا
هناك نحو 100 جسر حتى الان في
لم يتم التعرف عليها حتى هذه اللحظه من
معبر ام جلود في منبج مراسل العربيه جمعه
عكاش شكرا جزيلا لك
في ادلبوا على الرغم من الانتقال الى
اعمال رفع الانقاض وانتشال الجثث الا ان
فرق الانقاذ نجحت بانتشال طفل من تحت
الانقاذ منزله فيما افترشت جثث ضحايا
زلزال ارضيه مشفى حلب الجامعي نتابعه
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله عليك ان شاء الله عليك
يا شباب
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنا من ريف ادلب الصحفي محمد
الاشقر اهلا بك محمد اسمح لي انا ابدا
بالصور التي شاهدناها قبل قليل افراز جثث
لضحايا الزلزال المشفى لماذا ليس هناك من
امكانيه لنقلهم لدفنهم يبحثون عن اهاليهم
التعرف على هويتهم ام ماذا
قبل دفنها في المقابر الجماع ان تكرر لان
الصوره لم تكن واضحه والصوت لم يصلنا
ويبدو انه في مشكله بالتواصل معك لنحاول
ان تكرر من جديد تفضل
نعم نعم كنت اتحدث على ان
للوصول ذوي
الاستلام جثامين ذويهم ودفنهم اصولا ومن
لم يتم التعرف
طيب يبدو ان الاتصال سيء مع الصحفي محمد
الاشقر من ريف ادلب طبعا سنحاول العوده
اليه في سياق الخامسه
تتحرك من تحت صارت الحجار من حوالي
والعماره صارت تتحرك
فزعانين صار الحيطان تهر على الاولاد
البنايات عم تهبط على الارض
[موسيقى]
على اخواتي بس انا الحمد لله ما صابني شيء
انا واختي وطلعنا من البدايه ما بعرف كيف
فرق الانقاذ في تركيا تتمسك في البحث
والانقاذ على امل الاخير في العثور على
احياء تحت ركام انقاذ الزلازل والذي ضربت
عشر ولايات تركيه بعد مضي سبعه ايام عليها
ذكر مراسل العربيه ان فرق البحث والانقاذ
تواصل محاولاتها ضد عقارب الساعه مع
استمرار عمليات ازاله انقاذ المباني التي
اكتملت اعمال البحث والانقاذ فيها بعد
انقطاع الامال في العثور على احياء
وكما نشاهد هناك حمله شعبيه كبيره في اكثر
من دوله ومنها السعوديه الحمله الشعبيه
السعوديه للتبرع ان كان لسوريا وايضا
لتركيا عبر منصه ساهم تجمع حتى هذه اللحظه
اكثر من 300 مليون ريال كنا شاهدنا مع
مراسلنا من الرياض البدء في انطلاق طائره
جديده فيها المزيد من المساعدات لتصل
تركيا وايضا الاراضي السوريه رحله من قضى
في هذا الزلزال قد تنتهي في مقبره جماعيه
بولايه هاتاي التركيه حيث دفنت السلطات
اكثر من 5000 شخص الزميل عمار الهندي تفقد
المقبره واعد هذا التقرير
نحن في مقبره هاتايا الجديده التي استحدثت
لدفن ضحايا الزلزال المدمر هذه هي الصور
من مقبره هاتاي الجديده هذه الارقام على
القبور
للموتى توضع بعد ان يتم تصوير الضحايا
ووضع ارقام واعطائهم ارقام معينه ومن بعد
ذلك يتم هدفها تاتي الجثث الى تلك الزاويه
تصور الجثث وبعد ذلك يتم دفنها بارقام
حتى يتسنى لمن لم يعرف مصير اقاربه ان
ياتي ويسال عنه
ورغم الارهاق وقساوه الظروف الجويه يعكف
جيش من المتطوعين في اديمان على توفير
الطعام
للمتضررين من الزلزال ولعناصر الانقاذ
والاغاثه على حد سواء نتابع
ذهبنا الى هذه الصور في وسط الطريق والتي
هي تعكس الواقع من
المتطوعين الذين يقومون في هذه الاثناء
وعلى مدار الايام بتحضير الشاي وايضا
القهوه للعاملين ولكل الذين يريدون او
يمرون في المدينه وكما ان نرى ايضا هنالك
مجموعه الان من الشبان الذين حضروا من عده
مناطق الى هذه المنطقه وهم الان مع ساعات
الفجر الاولى
منهم من يستريح ومنهم من كان في الورشه
ينتظر عينه او برهه من الوقت ثم بعد ذلك
ينتقل وايضا على جانب الطريق هذه الصور
لهذه الاواني التي يطبخ فيها كما نشاهد
الان وهي للشوربه الساخنه من هذه الجهه مع
البطاطا وايضا للشوربه العدس والتي تقدم
منذ عشره منذ سته سبعه ايام الى كل من
يدخل المدينه من اهلها او ابلا العاملين
فيها او من الذين ياتون من المناطق الاخرى
نشاهد ايضا الاستراحه للعمال الذين ياخذون
الان قسطا من الراحه بعد 24 ساعه وهذه
الخيام التي نراها وهذا المطبخ هو عباره
عن تقديم الطعام والدعم واللوجستي لكل
الفرق ولكل الذين يمرون على الطريق حتى ان
الخبز والفاكهه وكل الاحتياجات من بطاطا
اضافتي الى مياه هذا المطبخ هو صوره مصغره
عن مئات المطابخ الموزعه والمنتشره على
طول المدينه والتي ايضا قامت بها الجمعيات
الاهليه وقامت بها الجمعيات المدنيه وقامت
ايضا بها الحكومه واذهب معك الى هذه
الصوره
المعبره جدا عن الالم لانتظار الذين تحت
الركاب لهذا العامل وايضا لاقاربه الذين
هم تحت الركاب هو يوقد
بنا ناري ماء يمكن ان يساعده ويخفف عنه
هذا البرد بالاضافه الى انه يبيت في
العراق
وهذه عوده للصحفي محمد الاشقر من ريف ادلب
محمد هل لك ان تكمل ما كنا قد بدانا به
فيما يتعلق بالجثث التي تفترش
مستشفى ادلب
نعم يعني
في مدينه جنديرس في ريف حلب وصلنا اليها
حديثا لنقل الصوره من هنا وعدت بالحديث عن
موضوع مشفى ادلب الجامعي طبعا الاليه
المعتمده لدفن القتلى نتيجه هذا الزلزال
هي انتظار واعطاء مهله لذوي
القتلى رفى عليهم من قبل احد اقربائهم او
معارفهم وان لم يتم التعرف عليهم من خلال
خلال هذه
المقابر الجماعيه التي جهزت من خلال الفرق
التطوعيه التي تم انشاؤها لهذا الموضوع
محمد خبرنا فيما يتعلق بما يحدث من خلفك
هل هناك عمليات لا زالت قائمه في محاوله
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه او لا
نعم يعني تحدثنا عن عمليات الانقاذ فنحن
الان في اليوم السابع لهذه الكارثه
بات امر الانقاذ مستحيلا جميع العمليات
التي تحدث الان هي عمليات انتشال ضحايا من
تحت الانقاض طبعا تشاهدون تماما خلفي
بالصوره حيه الصناعه في مدينه جنديرس هذا
الحي المدمر بشكل شبه كامل يعني البناء
الذي سلم ولم يدمر ولم يسوى بالارض قد هدم
يعني واصبح غير صالحا للسكن كهذا البناء
الذي يظهر امامكم على الشاشه طبعا تستمر
فرق الدفاع المدني في انتشال الضحايا من
بعض المباني اما بالنسبه للمباني التي تم
مسحها بشكل كامل كهذا الحي حيث تم مسح
جميع المباني وانتشال الضحايا من تحت
الانقاض تستمر فرق الدفاع المدني اشاره في
هذه النقاط ايضا
تحسبا لاي ابلاغ قد ياتيهم من احد عن وجود
ضحايا تحت الانقاض في احد الابنيه طبعا
تشاهدون الان ايضا الاهالي هنا الذين اتوا
الى الى احيائهم هؤلاء الناجين من هذا
الزلزال الذين اتوا الى هذا الحي منهم من
اراد ان يدخل الى منزله واخذ ما يمكن اخذه
من من المنزل بغيه الاستفاده منه في
المكان الذي لجاوا اليه سواء كان خيمه او
مركز ايواء او حتى عند احد من اقاربهم
طبعا يعني الوضع هنا في مدينه جنديرس هو
وضع كارثه وماساوي ان سمحت لي ان ان
استضيف معي متطوعا في الدفاع المدني وهو
السيد محمد العربي احد متطوعي الدفاع
المدني الذين ساهموا في عمليات الانقاذ
وانت الضحايا من تحت الانقاض على مدار
الايام السابقه اهلا وسهلا بك محمد
بالبدايه اذا بتحطنا بالحصيله النهائيه
الصادره عن مؤسسه الدفاع المدني نحن كدفاع
مدني عاملين بمناطق شمال غرب سوريا احصينا
لليوم
2168 ضحيه قتيل
1950 مصاب
طبعا ما زال عمليات البحث والانتشار
المستمره في منطقه ادلب وريف حلب
اعتمادنا حاليا بشكل كبير عم يكون على
اهالي وزاويه الضحايا بابلاغنا عن وجود
مفقودين ما زالوا تحت الركام طبعا
اهالي وزاويه القتلى وبالبدايه عم يبحثوا
عنهم بالمشافي اما ما بين الجرحى
المشافي في حال ما تم العثور عليهم عم
يرجعوا ببلغونا عن وجودهم تحت الركاب نعم
طيب هناك سؤال يخطر على بال الجميع في
تركيا المجاوره الى حد هذه اللحظه يتم
انقاذ ضحايا من تحت الانقاض لماذا هذا
الامر لم نجده في سوريا طبعا بشكل اساسي
اولا نقص الكبير بالمعدات نحن كنا بحاجه
الى رافعات ضخمه قادره على حمل اوزان اسقف
المنازل الاوزان ما بين 10 الى 15 طن
وربما اكثر كمان من هيك
في عنا نقص كان كبير من العادات بالاضافه
لنقص بالاجهزه المتطوره اللي قادره على
كشف احياء تحت الانقاض موجوده بالدول
المتقدمه قادره تتعامل مع الكارثه
سيد محمد طبعا هذه شهاده احد المتطوعين في
الدفاع المدني
المرير الذي تابعناه خلال الايام الماضيه
حتى هذه اللحظه من ريف ادلب الصحفي محمد
الاشقر طبعا نعود اليك في نشراتنا اللاحقه
شكرا جزيلا لك ومعنا من ريف حلب الصحفي
احمد ابو لؤي اهلا بك اخ احمد هل لك ان
تعطينا فكره عن المعلومات المتوفره لديك
والوضع في حلب
نعم تحياتي للساده المشاهدين يعني طبعا
الوضع
الكارثي ما زال يزداد تفاقما فبعد سته
ايام اليوم نحن في اليوم السابع على كارثه
الزلزال الذي القاتل الذي ضرب مناطق سوريا
طبعا واعلام فرق الدفاع المدني انتهاء
عمليات البحث بعد انقطاع الامل لديهم بعدم
ادخال الاجهزه الحديثه اجهزه التنصت من
اجل يعني الكشف عن العالقين يعني اوضاع
ماساويه اليوم يزداد عدد يعني القتلى يعني
حيث بلغ عدد القتلى
2168 يعني يتجاوز هذا الاعداد كحاله وفاه
واكثر من 2950 مصاب
طبعا الحيه الاكبر من القتلى كان من نصيب
جنديرس المنكوبه التي تقع في ريف عفرين
شمال حلب حيث بلغ عدد الضحايا 513 تليها
مدينه حارم ب 350 حاله وفاه اضافه سلقين
221 وفاه طبعا يعني اوضاع ماساويه نتجه
قليلا الى الوضع الطبي اليوم
المشافي اوضاع سيئه بسبب ضغط المصابين
بداخلها هم بحاجه ادويه الى معدات
لتشميدهم من اجل معالجه او طبعا يعني
معالجه
المصابين عنا معلومات عن الاصابات وحجمها
نعم يعني بعد ساعات الطويله ان خرج اي حدا
ناجي يعني هنالك اصابات بالغه كسور
بالاضلاع وغيرها وما شابه ليس كالناجين
خرجوا من بضعه الساعات الاولى يكون مجرد
روبوت طبعا ومن المصابين يعني حتى اليوم
هنالك من تعرضوا لاسماك نفسيه لانهم ظلوا
لساعات تحت الركام تحت الانقاذ يعني وضع
ساوي بكل ما تعنيه الكلمات فاتجه قليلا
الى اوضاع العائلات المفترسين الاراضي
طبعا هنالك
الاف الاف المباني المتصدعه حيث خرج منها
اهاليها وهي غير انيه يعني
للسكن يعني اليوم نجد نجد الاهالي مفترسين
الاراضي تحت اقسام الزيتون منهم عند
اقربائهم لربما في احتواء ربما ايضا لم
يساعد بهذه الفتره من ريف حلب الصحفي احمد
ابو لؤي شكرا جزيلا لك والى عطاء جنوب
تركيا ينضم الينا موفد العربيه عمار
الهندي اهلا بك عمار اين تتواجد الان انقل
لنا المشهد
اهلا ميسون
اهلا ميسون اسف لم اسمع السؤال جيدا فقد
سالت اين تتواجد الان انقل لنا المشهد من
عندك عمار
ميسون نحن نتواجد في وسط حي منكوب بالكامل
طبعا هنالك من عثر على الجثه التي ينتظرها
وهنالك من لم يعثر على الجثمان لذويه تحت
انقاذ هذه البنايات طبعا فرق انقاذ وعمل
وتعزيزات جاءت الى هنا الى هذا المكان في
التو قبل قليل كانوا اشتبهوا بان هنالك
شخص على قيد الحياه ولكن تبين بعد الفحص
بانه هاتف يرن ولكن للاسف صاحب الهاتف لا
يرد ايضا انا ساجول في الكاميرا
ميسون حتى تشاهد الصوره بشكل اوضح
هذه مثلا سيده لا ادري ان كانت تظهر هذه
السيده المنهاره تسلمت جثمان الشخص الذي
تنتظره وهو يعني
في هذه الكيس الاسود ساطلب من الزميل
المصور ان يقترب اكثر معي هناك على يسار
الشاشه هذه السيده المنهاره التي تبكي
ميسون كانت تنتظر لساعات وتلقت اخيرا
الجثمان الذي كانت تنتظره منذ ايام منذ
سبعه ايام نحن في اليوم السابع ولا يزال
الناس هنا ينتظرون جثامين
تخرج من تحت الانقاض طبعا الجميع هنا بدا
يعني يرتدي الكمامات لان ميسون رائحه
الموت بدات تنتشر في المباني التي لم تخرج
منها الجثانين بعد هنالك طبعا على يساري
هذا هذه عائله سوريه تنتظر ايضا عدد كبير
من الافراد تحت انقاذ هذا المنزل
امشي امشي امشي خليه يمر
يعني هنالك ارباك كبير
الجميع ميسون يعني هنالك من يبحث وهنالك
من ينتظر وهنالك جثامين نعم نعم ضغط كبير
وهنالك ايضا كما قلت لك
الجثامين التي
لا يتعرف عليها احد لمده 24 ساعه توضع الى
جانب البناء الذي تخرج منه
وفي حال جاء احد يتعرف عليها ياخذها
ويدفنها
بمعرفته وان لم يت يعني يتعرف عليها احد
خلال 24 ساعه يتم نقلها الى المقابر
الجماعيه
حيث يتم تصويرها تصوير الجثمان
والجثه وبعد ذلك تمنح رقم
وبعدها يتم دفنها
هذا المبنى الذي ستشاهدينه الان
مبنى لا يزال لا تزال الجثمين والجثث تخرج
منه
لا تزال الجثثمين تخرج منه
باعداد كبيره للاسف منذ الصباح
والعمل لازال مستمر عمار هل من اشارات انه
في تفاؤل انه ربما يكون هناك عمليه انتشال
من هو لا زال على قيد الحياه او لا لانه
بسوريا بعض المناطق تم الاعلان عن
الانتهاء من عمليه الانقاذ واصبح الموضوع
تحصيل حاصل فيما يتعلق بالتعاطي مع ان
الان المرحله هي مرحله انتشال الجثه
نحن اليوم شهدنا حاله خروج شخص على قيد
الحياه في هذا المبنى الذي يعني تشاهدينه
الان ميسون امضى 151 ساعه تحت الانقاض
واسمه عبد الله وسمعنا بان هنالك حاله
اخرى ولكن لا ليس لدي معلومات ما اذا كان
شاب او فتاه ولكن نعم اخرجوا حاله اخرى
على قيد الحياه بعد سبعه ايام ولكن صراحه
الان كل ما يخرج من تحت الانقاض 90 اكثر
من 90% واكثر واكثر حقيقه من هذا الرقم
يخرج اموات للاسف الشديد نحن في اليوم
السابع ميسون من هذا الزلزال والدمار لا
يزال متواجد الدمار هائل وهنالك يعني
العديد من الاسر التي لا تزال تنتظر الى
جانب هذا الركام
الجثامين تخرج وهنالك اطفال يعني جاءوا
وشاهدناهم اليوم منهم من يبحث عن صديقه
وهنالك من يبحث عن والده هنالك من يبحث عن
والدته
وبالتالي هذا الامر يعني
الجميع حتى ونحن نتحدث اليهم حينما نسال
هل لديك امل بانه بان الشخص على قيد
الحياه الاجابه تكون حتما يعني يا اما
الصمت الشديد والذي يعني يوحي بانه ليس
لديه امل او انه يحكي صراحه انه لا يريد
اكثر من الجثمان لدفنه ويحظى بدفن يعني
لائق يليق به وبمعرفته نعم ميسون
جنوب تركيا موفد العربيه عمار الهندي شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الحكومه التركيه فتحت تحقيقا موسعا مع
مقاولي البناء بسبب انهيار الاف البنايات
جراء الزلزال اشارت وزاره العدل التركيه
الى اعتقال 62 من مقاولين بناء في اطار
التحقيقات كما انشات مكاتب تحقيق في جرائم
الزلازل والوفيات والاصابات وقد شددت
وزاره العدل على ضروره اتخاذ خطوات فوريه
لجمع الادله وفرض اجراءات احترازيه بشان
المشتبه بهم في التحقيقات في تهم الاهمال
الذي افضى الى الموت حسب وصفها
لكن لماذا انهارت العديد من المباني في
تركيا عقب الزلازل بصرف النظر عن السبب
الواضح طبعا هو ان اي زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه
بامكانه تسويه المباني بالارض تحقيق لبي
بي بي سي سله الضوء على التحايل على
معايير السلامه الانشائيه في تركيا وفقا
للتقارير سمحت الحكومه التركيه ببناء
مبانئ بدون شهادات السلامه المطلوبه مقابل
رسوم ما جعل حتى المباني الجديده معرضه
للانهيار وتم تمرير مثل تلك الاعفاءات
القانونيه الفعاله منذ الستينات من القرن
الماضي اخرها في عام 2018
ولا طالما حذر المنتقدون من ان قرارات
العفو هذه قد تؤدي الى وقوع كارثه في حاله
وقوع زلزال كبير في سياق اخر قال رئيس
اتحاد غرف المهندسين الاتراك ومخططي المدن
في اسطنبول انه تم منحه ما يصل الى 75 الف
اعفاء لمبان في جميع انحاء منطقه الزلزال
المتضرره في جنوب تركيا
في اليابان يعيش ملايين الاشخاص في
اليابان في مباني شاهقه مقتظه بالسكان حيث
تعتمد سلطات معايير بناء تضمن سلامه
السكان وقت الزلزال وتختلف متطلبات سلامه
البناء بناء على كيفيه استخدام المبنى
وقربه من المناطق الاكثر تعرضا لخطر
الزلازل اذا تعتمد السلطات ومعايير
التعزيز البسيط في البناء
كمخمدات الحركه في هيكل المبنى للتحكم في
الاهتزازات الارضيه وصولا الى وضع الهيكل
باكمله فوق عازل عملاق للصدمات لفصل
المبنى عن حركه الارض
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من اسطنبول المهندس الاستشاري
مظهر شربجي اهلا بك استاذ مظهر اسمح لي ان
ابدا بقضيه الاعفاءات هذه هل هي فقط
محصوره بتركيا ام انه يطبق في كثير من
البلدان ربما
مساء الخير لكل للجميع المشاهدين والرحمه
للشهداء والشفاء للجرحى
عزيزتي اكيد بعد حادث تسونامي عام 2011
الضرب الزلزاليه التي دمرت المباني في
مدينه توتو اتخذ
تمنم العربي وفي معظم الدول العالم وايضا
اعتمادا على الزلزال الذي حدث في عام 1999
في تركيا تم اعتماد كودات كثيره كودات بكل
دوله هي اشتراطات
تعتقد تعتمد على
تخفيف من صدمات الزلازل وهذه الكودات وزعت
على معظم الدول وتم اتفاق عليها مثل
الاتحاد الاوروبي مثل دول اخرى اليابان
اخذت ع طرق للحد من الزلازل سوريا من دول
التي اعتمدت كود خاص فيها هو كود الزلازل
وميزت هنا بين الابنيه المرتفعه والابنيه
الازات الطوابق الخمس او السبع وما تحت
والسبع الطوابق وما فوق اعتمدت منها على
دراسات اسمها اشتراطات الزلازل الابن
السكنيه ويتم فيها اجراءات مختلفه
والابنيه العاليه يجب ان تدرس على الزلازل
سيد مظهر اسمح لي من خلال متابعتك ما بين
ما حدث في تركيا وما بينما حدث في سوريا
هل نجد انه سوريا كانت
اقل تضررا اذا ما صح التعبير رغم الماساه
طبعا الكبيره مقارنه بتركيا في ظل هذا
الكود الذي اتبعته او لا
نعم نعم هلا الابنيه التي وقعت في سوريا
حاليا هي ابنيه ممكن يكون فيها
ابنيه غير مرخصه فاللي سقطت اما الابنيه
المرخصه
لها هويه عمرانيه اخف قليلا بينما في
تركيا اكثر لانه هناك حالات اشكال عديده
من الانهيارات يعني كما حدث فيها تاي
وشفنا مجموعه الابنيه التي سقطت جمله
واحده
البناء الكبير هذا هذا يختلف عن ابني
المهاره او انشقت وهذا هو السؤال لانه
تركيا لم تتبع الكود الذي كان يجب عليها
اتباعه او لانه كان هناك نوع من الفساد او
الاعفاءات كمان والشهادات دون اليه
السلامه المطلوبه الاثنين معا صراحه هناك
البلديات هي من تمنح الرخص وانا لاحظت في
تركيا لا يوجد تدقيق للاضابير الهندسيه في
سوريا يجوز يجب ان يكون هناك اي اضباره
للابنيه مدروسه ومدققه من قبل مختصين في
تركيا ليس هناك سوء في الدراسات لكن هناك
سوء في التنفيذ والمقاولين قد يكونوا لهم
دور اساسي في سوء هذا البناء يعني نبدا من
الارض من
التربه اذا ما كانت التربه مدروسه على
بشكل جيد لتحمل الارتفاعات والاوزان
الكثيره ان توقف هذه العمليه لكن نجدها
مثلا كما حدث في انهيار مبنى متكامل فيها
طاي وميوله هذا واضح جدا لخلل في المعايير
التي وضعت سواء في الدراسه او في التنفيذ
وهنا عم نحكي عن المباني الجديده او
القديمه
منذ يومين الى الى اسطنبول انا عشته
المرحله برعبها ومشاكلها فلم في في عنتاب
القديمه
الانهيارات للمباني القديمه واعيش في
منطقه ابنيه قديمه لاحظ ذلك في الابنيه
الحديثه وهذا ان دل على شيء فهناك عدم
تطبيق لمعايير هندسيه هناك اشكاليات في
التربه هناك اشكالات في في عدم وجود
اشتراطات الزلازل في الابنيه الخمس طوابق
وما فوق الابنيه الحديثه نعم
حاليا قد يكون هناك اشتراطات لها اما اما
التي وقعت وشاهدت عليها
هي اكيد في مشكله في المواد
وهبوطات وتصدعات ليس لها علاقه لانه لماذا
ذلك نجد بناء بجانب بناء اخر بنفس ارتفاع
الطابق لو كان هناك شك
زلزاليه يمر تحت البناء يجب ان يقع
البنائين كما حدث في سرمدا نرجت انها طريق
واحد في في الداخل السوري يدل على فساد
ايضا ممكن يكون لانه وقعت الابنيه كلها
على هذا الشق على نفس الخط الزلزالي اما
بناء بجانب بناء بناء انهار وبناء بنفس
العمر بنفس العمر البناء فهناك قد يكون
اشكال كبير بموضوع لا نقول ان الهزه هي
كبيره نعلم انه الهزه الصب فوق السبعه هي
مدمره وهناك تلطف من الله رب العالمين على
على على العباد انه يجب ان يكون بالسبعه
فاصل ثمانيه هو البنيه التحتيه ايضا
ولذلك اجد ان هناك نعم المقاولون لهم دور
بالموضوع قد يكون الدراسات الهندسيه التي
لا تنفذ وفق معايير معينه ايضا اثرت على
هذا سؤال بعيد عن الموضوع ولكن انت اشرت
اليه كنت بغازي عنتاب
وانتقلت الى اسطنبول حديثا خبرنا باختصار
عن تجربتك
نحن نحن في
غزه الرابعه كانه
لم اشهد عام 2011 وحصل زلزال وشاهدته بام
عيني يعني اهتز البناء كاملا لكن لم يحدث
اي اي تشققات في البناء واهتز نفس الهزه
ودخت ووقعت الارض اما في عنتاب كان
القيامه قامت
وسمعت اصوات
البيتون وليس الفرش الذي يتكسر سمعته
كمهندس اصوات الاعمده مع الاساسات كيف ترج
يعني هذا اكيد لازم يكون مدمر لكن حابب
اذكر هون شغله على على انه يجب على
المقاولين والدول والمؤسسات خاصه المناطق
النشطه زلزاليا ان تعتمد التقنيات الحديثه
التي تعمدت بعد حدوث تسونامي في اليابان
والدول لديها كودات لكن يجب ان تبدا تبدا
بمعايير جديده التقنيات جديده للتداء
ارواح بين بين
المهندسين والمقاوين والوزارات المختصه
كان معنا من اسطنبول المهندس الاستشاري
مظهر شربجي شكرا جزيلا لك وحمد لله على
السلامه
شكرا لك شكرا
[موسيقى]
خلاص انا
حضرت الامم المتحده من ان حوالي خمسه
ملايين ونصف المليون سوري اصبحوا بلا ماوى
جراء الزلزال واقرت المنظمه الامميه
بالفشل في مساعده المنكوبين بشمال غرب
سوريا حيث دعا وكيل امينه عام الامم
المتحده الى تصحيح الاخفاقات في شمال غرب
سوريا باسرع ما يمكن وتقديم المساعده
الدوليه لاكبر قدر ممكن من الضحايا في
اشاره الى ان سكان شمال غرب سوريا يشعرون
بالتخلي عنهم ويتطلعون للمساعدات في اقرب
وقت
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا طبعا سنواصل معكم هذه التغطيه
للزلزال ولكن نتوقف امام بعض الاخبار
الخاصه بملفات اخرى صرح وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه بان المسؤولين الامريكيين يعترفون
اساسا في تصريحاتهم بان انفجارات نورد
ستريم هي من عملهم ويتحدثون عنها بسرور
ياتي هذا في وقت اكدت فيه المتحدث الرسمي
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخاروفا ان روسيا تحدثت مرارا عن تورط
الولايات المتحده ودول الناتو في تفجيرات
ستريم
قال كبير المفوضين النوويين الايرانيين
علي باقر كني ان المفاوضات في اطار تبادل
الرسائل غير المباشره بين طهران والولايات
المتحده مستمره وشدد المفاوض الايراني على
انه لا توجد اي عقبه امام الانتهاء من
الاتفاق النووي اذا تم تامين مصالح طهران
مشيرا الى ان المفاوضات تركز على العقوبات
الاقتصاديه
شهدت مدينه ليما عاصمه البيرو احتجاجات
شارك فيها الالاف مجددا للمطالبه باستقاله
رئيسه البلاد دينار بولوارتي التي تواجه
ازمه سياسيه واجتماعيه منذ توليها السلطه
قبل شهرين بدات التظاهرات التي قتل فيها
60 شخصا حتى الان بعد اطاحه الرئيس
اليسريه السابق بيدروك كاستيو بتهمه
القيام بمحاوله الانقلاب عبر قراره حل
البرلمان
اعلن البنتاجون عن رصد خلل في اجهزه
الرادار وعدم العثور على اي جسم طائر فوق
ولايه مونتانا امس السبت وذلك بعد ارسال
الطائره مقاتله للتحقق كما اكدت قياده
الدفاع الجوي لامريكا الشماليه نراد انها
ارسلت طائرات مقاتله للتحقق مشيره الى ان
الطائرات لم ترصد اي شيء يرتبط باشارات
الرادار وانها ستواصل مراقبه الوضع ياتي
اعلان بعد ساعات من اعلان كندا اسقاط
مقاتله امريكيه لجسم بخصائص مجهوله فوق
اقليم يكون الكندي
مشاهدينا الخامسه انتهت ولكن التغطيه
مستمره على راس الساعه موجز لاهم الانباء
مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
خلاص انا
نايمه
[موسيقى]
والعماره صارت تتحرك
اصاله رجفه الارض شوي رجعنا فزينا فزعانين
صاروا الحيطان تمر على الاولاد البنايات
عم تهبط على الارض
بس انا الحمد لله ما صار شيء انا واختي
وطلعنا من البنايه بعجوبه ما بعرف كيف
[موسيقى]
بشتغل لانه الباب كمان
خليك صاحي يا عمي خليك صاحي يلا
حبيبي يلا الله يقويك ما شاء الله عليك ان
شاء الله عليك
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
طبعا
[تصفيق]